foreign
we're back here we go again it's time
for facts to your friends
[Music]
we've got to change this music
I mean from the bottom of my heart
all right you know what we're at
Smashing Pumpkins time now I'll take
Smashing Pumpkins over that
and I think truly hit a low point it's
it's lower than low
as the producer of the show that's a no
[Laughter]
Okay so
so I made the internets really
uncomfortable the other day and so
here's here's what I wrote
on the Instagrams
this morning I plan to take my
seven-year-old daughter on a Valentine's
breakfast date I got up early and got my
workout done
I told my daughter we were going on a
date and she said no
she wouldn't go
I was crushed and it really made me sad
but my sadness is not hers to carry so I
told her I loved her to the moon and
back and I would love to take her on a
date anytime she would have me
I then wrote parents manage managing our
emotions is our job not our kids even
when it hurts
man people got opinions on that people
got opinions on that so I'm gonna
clarify
dig in a little bit and I am right and
you are not okay so here we go
here's some here's some clarity to that
Instagram post
the night before Valentine's Day I asked
my daughter hey I would like to take you
on a date tomorrow to get waffles or
pancakes just a special time with Dad
and and daughter she said no I don't
want to go I wanna have my regular
morning
and then go to school and Mommy drives
me to school
I disregarded her feelings
I I asked her and she said no and I just
blew right past it and I moved into my
little fantasy land that she wanted this
date as much as me and I was telling
myself the story it's going to be great
for both of us and then 25 years from
now she's gonna remember how how dad
always showed up on Valentine's Day I I
create all these stories
now here's some backstory here
I've been a ball of tension and
frustration and exhaustion uh writing a
book the process for me it takes
something from me I leave something on
the field
um particularly this last book because I
had to dig into some stories I haven't
wanted to dig into in a long time and
had to be really honest with myself I
ended up calling a counselor after
writing it not because it's so dark and
but I realized I'm not doing some of the
things that I'm recommending other
people do to make their lives more whole
and less anxious and helping them be
more well
I need to go take care of so it was hard
it was a hard process and this sounds
cheesy and woo-woo but writing drains
the bloody hell out of me it literally
takes something from me I got deadlines
and editor friends coming to town kids
trying to be a good husband being on the
road got a show that we're doing every
day
and over the years I've become pretty
good at stuffing it down one thing that
I feel really confident about is if I
say I'm gonna get it done I'll get it
done and I'll get it done to the expense
of everything around me including my own
health but I'll get it done I believe
strongly in that
and
kids absorb tension
also for self-preservation they have a
highly attuned neuroception so word
coined by Dr Steven Portis the poly
Bagel Theory guy and I'm Not Hook Line
and Sinker on polyvegle Theory but one
thousand percent I believe the science
is super clear
our bodies are always searching the
environment for threats
kids especially
if you think of it in evolutionary terms
they had to because they're tiny little
creatures
that always are scanning to say is that
guy safe is she safe is this situation
safe is that guy safe you ever
introduce your your kid to one of your
friends it's kind of sketchy
and they just hide behind your leg they
feel it they know
and I'm a thousand percent convinced
that my daughter feels the underlying
tension in my body
her little body's always scanned in the
world it senses my it sees my tense
shoulders and it hears the sharpness in
my voice it feels the tension in my
muscles when I hold her and so when she
says no this isn't her being a brat a
whiny little baby and I joke about it
all the time but that's not that at all
it's her trying to preserve herself
and I gotta live with that
I've created a world where my daughter
doesn't feel safe and I'm not abusive I
don't yell I don't hit
I don't swear
but I'm a nuclear reactor sometimes
especially when I don't take care of
myself especially when I'm lonely
especially when I'm not honest about how
I'm feeling
and so if you've ever listened to
anything I've said
three critical important things are
happening so listen to me super super
carefully I can't think of anything I've
got more important to share than this
right here
number one
I'm gonna honor my daughter's request
for bodily autonomy
she feels unsafe around a nuclear
reactor which is what I've been lately
I'm gonna teach her through my actions
that she should learn to trust her body
and this also comes with consequences I
took her brother out
we go to breakfast every Tuesday I went
ahead and took him because that was our
normal routine and she missed a great
time and we hung out with the wait staff
and we made jokes now we've become
friends with the people at Waffle House
I love those guys and we ate too much we
had a blast she missed it so there was
some consequence there
number two
if I force her to go or I force her to
kiss me good night or I force her to
give me a hug when I get home from work
I'm teaching her that when some man
comes along
who is bigger than her or stronger or
has more power than her she should bow
before him and let him use her bodies
away to make himself feel better
and I refuse
to let my daughter go through the world
thinking it's her job to make sure the
men in her life are all happy and fine
especially at the expense of her body I
won't do it and I'm going to teach her
at a young age
that she has autonomy and she gets to
say no
period
and if her saying no makes me sad or
hurts my feelings that's for me to deal
with because she does not have the power
to change my feelings cause she's seven
she weighs about 14 pounds she doesn't
have that power I'm not going to give it
to her
that brings me number three my
daughter's seven your kids 14 17 11 3
however old they are they don't have the
power to hurt your feelings or to make
you sad or to make you angry you are in
control of that and if you Outsource it
to your kids they will try to carry that
burden as long as they can until it
finally crushes them
when I took a step back I realized I
wanted to build some relational Equity
with my daughter on Valentine's morning
because it would be a gift for me
for me had very little to do with her I
wanted to take her out on a date that I
designed against her wishes because I
thought it'd be great for her
it's not my daughter's job to make me
feel okay she can't carry that burden
and when I look around the landscape
I've worked with young people for two
decades
moms and dads our kids are being buried
under our expectations that they make
sure that we're all okay
that they get the jobs we want them to
have they drive the cars we think they
should drive they'd marry who we think
they should marry that they work they
get made and they major in the thing we
think they should major in
that we show up to the holidays that we
describe we prescribe for them even
though they can't afford it or they're
exhausted or they're working like crazy
they got two little ones
it's their job to make sure those little
ones are in our house so that we can
have our they're dying under our
expectations that they prop us up
and as the world has gotten increasingly
more and more lonely parents we have
transferred our need for connection onto
our kids
and now I've got
countless the number of moms and dads
I've met with who are like no my 14 year
old daughter's my best friend God help
that 14 year old
me and my 16 year old are best friends
like my heart breaks for that 16 year
old
because she can't carry your adult
friendship he can't carry your
friendship you gotta have grown-up
friends
and let your kids have their own friends
and here's one more note
a mother wrote me and asked about
spilling her guts after her husband died
she wrote she read this post
um and she wrote me and said hey my
husband died of cancer and now I'm
feeling guilty because I dumped all this
out and my kids saw it all
letting your kids see you grieving and
letting your kids see you devastated is
an Incredible Gift such a gift
because your kids if if they lose their
dad
or dad loses his job
or Mom is sick or whatever is going on
in your life
they're going to be sad and devastated
and frustrated too
and if Mom and Dad turn into concrete
statues and these stoic robots who just
go through life like nothing's affecting
them I don't want to show the kids I
don't want to scare the kids then what
happens is you don't scare the kids but
the kids go crazy because they feel it
and they look at Mom and Dad to see how
they're supposed to be responding mom
and dad are just walking around like
automatrons
so the greatest gift you can give your
kids is to let them know that you're sad
let them know that you are devastated by
grief
just don't force your kids to make to be
responsible for making you feel less sad
and less heartbroken that's not their
job here's how this looks in the real
world okay I wrote this one I wrote this
down mom is feeling so so sad like this
is this is you this is a mom talking to
their kids
mom is feeling so so sad I lost my
friend my friend died and I'm hurting so
much inside
and I'm gonna go see a counselor visit
with my friends because I'm in so much
pain and if you're ever hurting I want
you to know you're not alone and I'm
always here for you for a hug a good cry
or to go for a long walk or maybe even
sneak some Girl Scout cookies
whatever you need I want you to know
that I love you and if you ever heard
anything like this
um
I'll be here for you
that's different than
mommy's feeling so sad I lost my friend
my friend died and I'm hurting so much
inside come give me a hug so I can feel
better your hugs make me feel so much
better I need my hug so I'm not so sad
and lonely
now Mom has shifted her the burden of
her pain onto her kid and that kid's
gonna begin looking for ways to make mom
less sad less painful less angry to make
Dad less reactive
that's not their job
so back to my daughter I hugged my
daughter and said I love you and I can't
wait to go on a date with you when
you'll have me
and to be honest
I went in my bedroom and I wept I cried
hard
not just because my daughter said no to
me on our Valentine's Day but because I
know I've been a mess
and it spills onto people at work spills
onto my wife
announcement on my kids
I've been avoiding dealing with my own
crap for a long time and my daughter's
body called me out on it
it's my job to deal with my emotions not
hers
our jobs adults to be the adults and to
go seek out relationships and support
and help from other adults not our kids
they got enough of their own crap to be
carrying to not carry us